bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got brad
and hyder here i'm super excited about
this we're going to talk about an
announcement they
have uh let's first get started though
maybe both of you just introduce
yourselves
and the companies you work for hi
everyone this is heider uh i
am the chief marketing officer at okcoin
and i'm brad i'm co-founder of
unstoppable domains
awesome so brad maybe let's start with
you uh what is the news
that ensemble domains and okay coin have
so uh okaycoin has integrated blockchain
domains for the purposes
of sending and receiving crypto in the
exchange and the reason why this is such
a big deal is because this is
the first time a exchange has supported
this standard
this blockchain domain standard human
readable names instead of
long crypto addresses has been widely
adopted in the wallet
community uh but not in the exchange
community yet and if you're a crypto
user
you're using both so you really need if
in order to actually get rid of your
long hex addresses you need exchanges
as well as wallace to support this got
it
so hyder maybe let's just zoom out and
kind of go backwards first of just like
what is the problem
right if you guys are implementing this
as a solution what was the problem that
you identified
and we're trying to solve look
ultimately
we can all agree that the current form
of uh wallet addresses is a poor user
um i think when these things probably
got invented there was no product
manager or user
experience person in the room and
they've played their part
and i think it's it's due time that
these things evolve and become better if
we're all about
welcoming people who are non-crypto
natives
essentially newcomers we have to take a
really hard look at these problems
and the reality is there's so much
goodness in crypto in its nature
it's more interoperable than traditional
money so for example
pomp if i'm sending you us dollars i
have to send it via
a wire transfer uh there's no
interoperability between banking systems
or even consumer
fintech apps like cash app or paypal
you're kind of struck in there in their
wall garden if you will
with crypto you we we all know it's
pretty easy to send and receive
crypto from one wallet to another
exchange and vice versa
but the problem the key friction point
has been this
long string of address one has to copy
and then put into your new
sort of place where you want to receive
it or send it to a friend
say i'm sending you some crypto i now
have to send you this long string of
address
or a qr code i look i was never a fan of
qr codes either so maybe this is beef
against qr codes
but generally we want to solve that
piece which is
how do we simplify interoperability and
bring the best out of crypto in the form
that
really helps us win long term and
this is not just about okay coin this is
about
everyone involved in this industry it
should be really really simple and easy
to take value crypto value out of okay
coin into another wallet
whether hardware or what have you or
into another exchange
or into another wallet and that is tough
today
that's especially tough if i have to
tell one of my friends who's not in the
crypto industry to come in and do the
same thing
so for example if a friend of mine
started a wallet i have to send him or
her some crypto to get them
to get started and we believe
unstoppable domains is the right
solution to remove that
that friction that sort of
anxiety-inducing experience
that perhaps if i get one string wrong
in that wallet address
it might go to the wrong pump and i
might never get my money back
and the qr code thing look it's better
than the long string address
but is it really shareable like are you
just gonna like text around
and and message around a qr code i don't
think people are there yet with qr codes
and so with unstoppable wallet addresses
it
you know it's as simple as hydra dot
crypto or popped out crypto or brad
crypto and now you can send and receive
and share that address publicly it has
privacy features
you're not exposing your private key or
your public address
so there's a lot of goodness here and
that's that's the main reason
why we wanted to implement this is
ultimately make it really easy for
people who are coming in
to start using crypto not just to invest
but also to share among their family and
friends
or perhaps use crypto for other
economical transactions like if you're a
freelancer you want to
you know transact using crypto uh across
the border
so that that's the key motivation yeah
it makes a ton of sense i always joke
with people uh you know everyone's had
that feeling when you go to send
uh even a small amount um and you've got
to put in that address
and your heart starts beating and it's
kind of like the m m song right
it's like you know uh literally you feel
like you're about to start sweating
because you want to screw it up
so uh so it makes a ton of sense brad
maybe talk a little bit about
how unstoppable domains and ok coin came
together um
and you know why okay coin and
um kind of how did you guys think about
entering into
uh the exchanges and getting exchanges
to start adopting this on top of wallets
yes i mean i think we you know we
started with wallace um because
they were an easier place to start
frankly
um they are it's a bit simpler for them
to adopt new technology based on the way
that they're
structured when you are holding people's
private keys you have this
uh gigantic security i'm not gonna use
the the term honeypot i think that
they're actually quite
um you know exchanges there's plenty of
exchanges now that are extremely
extremely good at security but they have
this problem and so
uh it's been easier to start with
wallets also there's a lot of
sending and receiving on wallets whereas
with exchanges there's a lot more
sending and receiving to yourself
so that was a good place to start but
ultimately
if you think about this industry we have
a
uh one trillion dollar asset class where
the money is being transferred on the
equivalent of ip addresses
so like this does not look like a
sustainable system uh to anyone inside
of crypto or anyone outside of crypto
and if you're trying to get people
inside
crypto uh you're going to need a system
that
is that has better user experience and
the user experience
of a domain name which is effectively a
username for you crypto
uh reminds people of what happens in the
regular world reminds people of their
paypal addresses or their
cash up or their venmo or whatever so uh
it's a very clear and simple
form factor uh the way we got the way we
got um
connected in with okay coins so hide and
i've actually known each other for quite
a little while here
um and i've been talking for quite a
while and when he uh when he joined okay
coin he you know he essentially you know
he essentially said i'm going to make
this uh
i'm going to help make this a uh
a top-tier innovative exchange and has
said from the beginning
that the goal here has been a better
user experience
uh because that's what's critical and
the thing that's been pretty
you know unique about you know our
conversations and this partnership is
how
uh focused uh the okaycoin team has been
on the user experience
broadly like the user experience of
uh sending crypto more broadly uh not
just about
uh you know getting more money into okay
coin for example
um and i think that those kinds of bets
are what the crypto community needs
and that's what's going to get us to
this interoperability place and i think
once we have the interoperability then
it's going to be may the best
may the best application win um and and
so i think that the the top applications
will
will will wind up benefiting even more
from supporting
uh interoperability so and heider you
guys are obviously the first exchange
to do this um so maybe talk a little bit
about like
what drove that decision making um and
did you want to make sure you were the
first was it just hey we thought this
was the right experience for users and
we happened to be the first you know can
i just talk through a little bit of the
decision making from your guys end
um look we'll take our wins when we can
have it uh
so yes there is a sense of you know
a feel good when you're when you're the
first there's a sense of risk too which
is kind of nice and i think we have to
we have to put our skin in the game a
little bit here um
the the being the first piece really
boils down from
us wanting to deliver optimal user
experience so
there's an argument to be had that
perhaps uh
you know with with the engineering power
we have
you know we should consider building
something like this internally
well the challenge is we could create
something that's sort of a naming system
within
the okay coin ecosystem but that doesn't
really foster interoperability because
we're not well positioned to then
convince other walleye companies
uh and other exchanges to adapt our
protocol or our living structure
this is where we think it's it's one of
those innovations that
i i personally don't think and the
company doesn't think uh is one that
should be built
by exchanges themselves i think we
should adapt something like unstoppable
because they're on the path to achieving
that true interoperability
uh so the look it's really the user
experience we wanted to be the first
we wanted to make this a simple
experience it's it's really
such an easy thing to do from an
engineering standpoint to integrate
these guys
it's really easy to work with them as
well and ultimately it delights our
customers we're seeing it on twitter
today
um people who already use unstoppable
are excited about this integration uh
because now
if their funds are in one of those 40
wallets they can bring it over to
okay coin have some fun like use it for
earn uh
or high-yield features uh use it for
trading into other assets and then take
it back to a wallet really seamlessly
uh so there's a sense of excitement
we're happy to be the first
hopefully this encourages other
exchanges
to adapt it as well because that's where
things start to get
uh really interesting and that's that's
really the rationale
yeah it makes a ton of sense uh brett
maybe talk a little bit just about
and heider mentioned this earlier of uh
while there's a single address that i
can share like
pomp.crypto uh there's still some
privacy features and things that prevent
uh me from exposing kind of the public
address and all that so maybe just talk
through
for somebody from an actual user
experience standpoint if they've got an
ok
coin account and now they've got this
unstoppable domain
how that actually works in terms of they
just send the domain
but what can people see what can they
not see so
it depends on how you configure there's
um there's a few different ways that you
can go about it but ultimately if you're
sending money into an exchange it's a
little bit a little bit easier because
they have these kind of like
pots of uh pots of money um so it's hard
to so you can't necessarily discern
what's mine versus what's yours
um if it's a self-custody wallet there's
a couple of
there's a lot of extra things that you
can do um
that are not quite uh not quite
available yet
but for an exchange it's kind of by
default because they have these uh they
have these pots of money
um and just and just kind of in
in general i think that the the reason
why um
you know exchanges should do this is the
user experience
i think the reason why exchanges will do
this is because
uh it helps with deposits so if you have
a if you have a domain name attached to
your okay coin addresses
that is going to facilitate deposits
into the exchange
i'm not saying that's the only reason
you should do it or the only reason you
did it
um but that is a that is an advantage
and
i think haider kind of touched on this
briefly but i think we're
where we see it is sort of like i guess
crypto switzerland
um we're we're integrating in with in in
with everybody
um and i think that's one of the reasons
why you haven't seen solutions like this
come from existing crypto wallets and
exchanges is because
uh they're kind of in a you know they're
they're in a competitive market
uh and it would be hard for them to you
know kind of
cooperate in that way um whereas you
know something like
you know something like us we can just
sort of uh go in and plug in with
plugging with everybody got it and in
terms of
uh when you guys both think through this
and you're kind of
uh obviously in partnership but thinking
from two different sides
uh does this really force the hand of
other exchanges like should we expect
uh two years from now every exchange has
support uh for these kind of human
readable domains or do we think that
uh some maybe just not a priority and
they won't actually do it
i think less than two years uh yeah i
think it's uh
i think we're gonna see a lot of
movement um we're already seeing a lot
of movement and i think this is just the
this is just this is the this is the
beginning of the wave
got it i think from from my standpoint
it's
uh thinking about it from a consumer
point of view i as a
crypto user want to see that happen um i
there there's different value
propositions on different exchanges
and different wallets and the ability to
move around
really easily and without you know
having that sweaty experience that we
were talking about i think is it's
something i want
personally and i think uh i hope that
other exchanges are going to follow
suit quite quickly because it helps i
think build up the ecosystem and
arguably
uh crypto has been around now for you
know a decade
or so right and there there's a debate
to be had on whether we're moving fast
enough on the overall adoption
have we plateaued have are we just
converting you know crypto natives into
into the existing communities are we
just talking to each other in an echo
chamber
and uh i continue to look at cache app
and other
consumer fintech apps and their growth
accelerates the minute they add the
simplest form of
a crypto entry point uh
are we over complicating things in the
crypto world
and then you know traditional finance
and crypto or
fintech companies are looking at this
stuff and saying oh cool they designed
something really
amazing let us take the mvp of that and
onboard the rest of the people who've
been on the fence because the way we're
doing it
in a simple form is an easier way to
onboard
uh those folks without intimidating them
with all the crypto speak and
and the user experience so i think um i
think
i think exchanges should really pay
attention to to that particular trend
uh because the threat is not other
exchanges crypto exchanges it's
perhaps the com the bigger competition
is consumer finance companies
this is something i really like about
hydra's approach and i don't hear this
from a lot of from a lot of crypto folks
which is that you know we've got
whatever it is 100 million crypto users
right now or something like that where
the goal is to get to a billion
and he's worried about the big guys
coming and taking our lunch after all of
this hard work
and i don't hear that from other crypto
people they're usually they're
they're i think they are usually you
know we're in our bubble
you know patting each other on the back
talking about how great things are going
and they are going great
uh but at the same time because they're
going so well uh we are getting the
attention
of these much much more uh sophisticated
companies
and they're better at user experience
like hands down they are better user
experience
and uh we need to we need to step up our
game because those next billion crypto
users are coming
and the question is uh who gets them and
and that's
that is i think the value proposition of
uh of human readable names is getting
getting those
uh getting that next billion people on
right from the start like never even see
those hex addresses
like that's gonna be the way uh that we
can much more easily bring on the next
billion people
yeah i couldn't agree more uh before we
wrap up i want to ask both of you just
to
kind of look forward into the future
again you know whether it's five
ten years uh forward how are these
uh and the use of these human readable
names going to
evolve right so maybe brad you could
talk about just across the entire
ecosystem and
how to you could talk about kind of not
only what else you guys are looking to
do with this but how it fits into kind
of how an exchange would really build
this out
but just how does the human readable
name kind of become the
the core part of this industry and kind
of where do we evolve
to so i think the advantage that you get
when you get
so because a blockchain domain is a
crypto asset stored inside of your
wallet
you control it completely it gets you
that interoperability
uh it means that it's tamper proof
essentially nobody can take it away from
you unstoppable domains can't take it
away from you
and because you have that assurance it
enables you to go and build a lot of
different things on top of it so it
starts with payments
uh there was a feature to tie a real id
your twitter account to your domain name
so that you can have more
of a sense of who it is that you're
paying but the user still controls all
of that information and decides which
twitter
uh which twitter handle to attach to
their domain and can decide to attach
other information to their domain
so what you're seeing is kind of like a
bottom-up way to start identifying
identifying a person um could be pseudo
anonymously identifying them but still
identifying them
uh a person or end or party uh
in order to be able to start doing more
complicated transactions with them
and you know in the regular world if i'm
doing some sort of a transaction
i'm not usually sending it to some
anonymous set of letters and numbers
i usually have some information before
before i before i do that transaction
i think that's the thing that's going to
allow us to start doing more things
uh there's already pretty interesting
use cases of
uh these uh unstoppable domains beyond
just the wallet
uh thing that we're focused on today uh
the one that i'm continuing to explore
is publishing content
on these domains so i think in the
future
what this this could potentially become
is sort of your
access into a user-owned internet and
and you've probably heard us uh talk
about this uh
in context of the stx partnership
they're you know
attacking this uh issue from a different
angle
with unstoppable domains i could see a
future where
this is your entry point into web3 into
a ecosystem of web3 apps
uh it also is an address that you can
use to transact
uh with people and yourself across
different platforms
and then it's also a place essentially a
real estate that is truly your
real estate on the internet it's not the
real estate you get through verisign and
icann which is sort of a leased
real estate i think a lot of people
don't understand this concept
that if you buy a domain on godaddy or
any other registrar domain registrar
you're not really a true owner you're
just simply leasing it and that fee can
change
and vary from year to year and by the
way you don't have privacy you're
actually gonna pay for privacy
i think it's like nine bucks or ten
bucks a year and
kid you not there's no privacy with that
package i
swear to you i have bought domains i
have opted into that privacy package
and there i start getting calls from web
developers and seo experts
and you know so that i it's questionable
back to your question about the future
of these things i think it's
uh an identity system or it could be a
universal identity system into
your access into web3 into an ability
for you to transact with people
using the simple domain and then thirdly
having this real estate on the internet
that no one can take away from you it's
tamper resistant it's
censorship resistant and it's true
ownership so you can publish
content um say you're you know for the
lack of better example your wikileaks
uh there's it's gonna be really hard for
the future wikileaks to be taken down
for the good or bad yeah look i i think
that people are drastically
underestimating this and you know
kudos one obviously to brad and your
team for uh for making this all possible
and kind of building the technical stack
and then
hide there for you guys to just be so
forward thinking i think and really
understanding kind of the value of a
great user experience that
reduces friction for uh for people both
that are already in kind of bitcoin and
crypto but also for those that uh have
yet to uh to kind of join
so um you know i want to appreciate both
of you guys coming on and talking about
this but it just seems to be like this
is a no-brainer
and i definitely agree uh with both of
you that this will become kind of an
industry standard over time
um so what what is the way if somebody
wants to
get on board right uh do they go through
just the ok coin normal account
creation and then they can uh elect to
do this do they need to go to
unstoppable domains just talk through
kind of uh people who have
kind of heard about this and i want to
do it what's the best way to send them
to uh to go participate
uh there's there's really two type of
people um that
are going to be on boarding one is the
segment of people who
already have an unstoppable domain it's
easy for them
they just come in create an okay coin
account if they already have an ok coin
account they don't need to do much more
and when you go in the withdrawal flow
you can now enter
your unstoppable domain and withdraw or
deposit
uh into okay coin using an unstoppable
domain
the the thing with uh unstoppable
domains the way it's structured is
you typically your your entry point into
using it
whether you're on the wallet side or
exchange side is the withdrawal flow
so say you want to deposit into a coin
you're going to go into your wallets
withdrawal flow
enter your uh unstoppable domain address
and then okay coin will receive it right
or you can receive it in okay
now if you're a brand new user you don't
have an unstoppable domain you're
hearing this podcast you want to start
with unstoppabledomains.com
you want to go ahead and purchase a
domain it ranges anywhere between 20 and
40
depending on how how customized you want
it to be
and then once you have that domain
locked and loaded you want to configure
it with your wallet or your
wallet addresses and that's it basically
you're you're done there and then you
can start using it
to move money around or to move crypto
around
awesome unstoppabledomains.com
okaycoin.com
you guys are get your legends for
pulling this off so congratulations to
both of you
uh i highly suggest everyone go check it
out and uh we'll talk again next time
sounds good thanks for having us by the
way anyone a last teaser anyone
uh who who actually uses unstoppable
domains on okcoin
is automatically entering into a 10 000
giveaway
so odds are great i'm just saying
i love it all right thank you guys so
much we'll do it again